[Musique]
dans ce lycée de drancy où les cas de co
vide se multiplient quinze classes ont
été fermées
environ 500 élèves qui vont donc devoir
suivre un enseignement à distance
le président de la république décide
seul et il décide toujours en retard
donc maintenant il faut avoir le courage
de prendre des mesures fortes
il faut que les écoles ferment et
profiter des vacances scolaires du mois
d'avril comme on aurait dû le faire en
février donc oui je pense que c'est un
choix responsable de dire que tant que
nous pouvons faire autrement que prendre
des mesures de confinement strict et
fermer les écoles il faut faire
autrement c'est le choix qui a été fait
par le présent la république et je pense
que c'est un choix responsable 41
directeur médicaux de crise de l'ap-hp
assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
alerte il évoque une situation de
médecine de catastrophe et dit se
préparer à devoir je les cite faire un
tri des patients afin de sauver le plus
de vies possible mes collègues des
services de réanimation en ile de france
ont appelé à l'aide
parce que le tri des malades les plus
urgents qui devront être réanimé en
priorité va s'imposer
on dit que la déprogrammation c'est
faire du tri de malades et on commence à
faire une assimilation entre le fait on
des programmes dont contre il est malade
donc on nous a dit que lors de la
première vague on n'avait pas trier les
malades
pourquoi là alors qu'on a un niveau
trois fois inférieur à la première vague
on nous dit qu'on tri des malades il
faut avancer les vacances de pâques pour
les gamins et une fermeture des écoles
en profitant des vacances de pâques
également et en avançant ses vacances de
deux semaines et en prolongeant faisant
réellement au mieux
voilà si vous voulez quelques pistes je
vois beaucoup de conseils qui sont
donnés par les uns par les autres qui
vous dit j'aurais dû faire ceci ou on
aurait dû faire cela
enfin je regarde aussi ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays européens jockey des
choix différents coins des faits de
confinement d'ailleurs plus ou moins
strictes qu'on filme en régionaux de
confinement nationaux avec des résultats
qui sont malheureusement reconnaissons
le décevant une semaine après marseille
c'est un nouveau carnaval spontané et
non déclarés dans les rues de sète
200 personnes qui ont défié d
interdiction de se rassembler prétextant
la tradition de l'événement après la fin
du procès le tribunal correctionnel de
paris a rendu ce matin son jugement dans
la sphère du médiator ce médicament pour
traiter le diabète utilisé comme coupe
faim est accusé d'avoir causé la mort de
plusieurs centaines de personnes
le groupe servier écopent de plus de
deux millions sept cent mille euros
damende son ex numéro deux jean philippe
seta de quatre ans de prison avec sursis
et l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament est elle condamnée à 300 3000
euros d'amendé pour avoir failli à son
rôle de police sanitaire
les 6500 parties civiles se sont vu
allouer 180 millions d'euros de dommages
et intérêts selon un premier calcul
j'attends peut-être une condamnation
aussi de la part du parti socialiste de
ces propos parce qu'on voit bien c'est
qu'ils sont très divisés en leur sein
qu'il n'y a pas de ligne claire
finalement et je le déplore les propos
de vaudrait plus bas et la perspective
qu'elle soit candidate pour le parti
socialiste pour la région ile-de-france
m'inquiète au but la conception de la
république dans un tweet audrey pulvar
précise son propos et affirme que dans
une réunion non mixtes lgbt cuit plus
elle se terrer écouterez quand des
personnalités de gauche je suis pas là
pour eux polling avec audrey pulvar
utilisent ces concepts qui au fond
interdisent à des personnes parce qu'ils
ne sont pas les victimes directement de
parler au nom des victimes
alors on est dans une grande confusion
les réunions segmenté selon la couleur
de sa peau sa religion ou son sexe ça
divise le combat alors qu'en face la
finance eux ils sont unis nous nous
sommes nombreux mais divisés timide mais
un sillage tout de même derrière la
coque
les verts qui veulent se déplace pour la
première fois depuis une semaine
encadrés et tracté par sa flottille d'
escort
une fierté pour les égyptiens qui ont
bataillé jour et nuit
[Applaudissements]